[Music]
[Applause]
well hello everybody welcome to fat man
I'm Batman I am not Kevin Smith as I'm
pretty sure you guys can all tell Kevin
is doing Kevin [ __ ] out in the world
which is like you know millionaire
playboy stuff except nerd [ __ ] with the
flash so he will be back with me next
Saturday this area the 24th I don't know
how dates work but soyeah for tonight we
wanted to have a kind of special post
Black Panther opening weekend discussion
about all things
Wakanda all things to chala all things
that are changing lives and altering
courses of destinies in the world and
then after that I'm gonna have a little
roundtable conversation which will be
less than roundtable more a you know how
you go to the movies and you hang on the
parking lot after the movie for like an
hour and just talk about everything
we're gonna pretend this is the parking
lot so yeah I've seen Black Panther now
three times I know I'm where I got my my
my frequent flyer miles to what Conda
I'm working on it and I keep every time
I've seen it my feeling about the movies
changed a little bit the first time I
saw it was at the premiere which because
I got it like that
I call them favors I don't really have
it like that not anymore
and and that experience was was kind of
profound for the the weird feeling of
Hollywood rallying around something that
had never really rally around before but
I also didn't know what to expect out of
the movie you know like I've saw the
trailers I lived for the trailers I
reviewed the trailers and talked about
how much I felt like the movie was gonna
mean to me and you know I had built it
up in my head and even the build up in
your head made it with the idea that I
didn't know what the movie was the
trailers were incredibly nonspecific you
know you you watch this trailer ok well
I get that Michael B Jordan is playing
like Dwayne Wayne from different world
but like really [ __ ] bad and like I
get that Wakanda
is kind of a little bit like zoom under
but like more badass like you just get
these weird impressionistic blushes of
the movie which is all I ever really
want from a trailer like I don't need
you to tell me everything that truck can
happen it's like why go to a movie where
I know oh hey it's Jurassic world guess
what happens the monsters get out again
and you know they're pretty blonde dude
has to save everything again I didn't
know what I was going to get going into
Black Panther and so my first viewing of
it was first stripping away all of the
kind of barnacled expectations I had for
it for like six months and and trying to
drill down into what it was and and I
found myself fascinated by the world I
found myself transfixed by everything
that Ryan Coogler and his design
department in his costume department
just managed to summon for this movie I
mean it looks unlike anything at like
what Conda is a more fully realized
place than Asgard is and we've had as
guard for a long [ __ ] time but you
know you never have a sense that if you
walk down an alley in Asgard you will
find anything interesting but I
absolutely feel that if I end up lost in
Wakanda like it is going to be the most
amazing bad night I've ever had you know
like every character on that screen just
popped like they had so much energy so
much life and it was funnier than I
expected it to be you know and I don't
even know why I didn't expect it to be
funny maybe it's cuz I didn't know what
the [ __ ] to expect but you get i mean
Cherie is like a bolt of lightning from
the skies and she just enlivens every
scene she's in you know Nakia is she has
agency she wants things she's absolutely
committed to expanding the wakandan
influence in the world and changing
lives for the better and a Koya is just
the [ __ ] most badass character I've
seen on screen since Valkyrie in Thor
Ragnarok hey the two of them should be
friends like they should just roll
together that would be amazing
like I would watch the [ __ ] out of that
movie
you know like there's there's so much
wonderfulness in that movie that's just
the women I mean not even talking about
kill manga really who just [ __ ]
Michael be just Swagger's his way all
over that movie like it's oh I'm gonna
steal this from you this belongs to me
now I'm sorry
T'Challa this movies mine every scene
he's in he's just totally absconded with
it and and who the [ __ ] knew that
Winston Duke would be the dude we'd be
talking about like where'd he come from
how did Baku turn into this magnetic sex
panther God person and I am super
[ __ ] thankful because you do not see
a bunch of thick brothers on screen that
much anymore just swallowing desire from
the internet I am thankful for him for
assuring in a new age where dudes don't
have to look like chadwick michael b
they can have a little heft on them but
but i I was feeling like I was missing
something a little bit the first time I
saw Black Panther there was all if it
wasn't yelling for me in the way that I
kind of hoped it would and then I sort
of second time I start opening night I
went to the ArcLight Theatre in
Hollywood and a couple blocks away and
it was it was a similarly moving
experience the way the the premiere was
like Hollywood royalty all came out
dressed an African royalty garb and it
was this it was like [ __ ] black
shirts who the best black church you've
ever been to the opening night was like
the best barbecue you've ever been to in
that everybody was [ __ ] there every
every black person I knew in Hollywood
rolled out that night
every black TV writer every black a
movie writer every every person who is
either of color or an ally decided that
that was going to be the night we were
all going to kind of ingest this
together and and the the feeling in that
room the feeling in the parking lot the
feeling in the lobby the feeling at the
bar was just of we did it you guys like
we we we have been for a very long time
as black creators in Hollywood trying
our best to tell our stories trying our
best to get the the the little signposts
of our cultural specificity on screen
but we've also been very acknowledgement
very you know acknowledging the idea
that
sometimes we've had to subsume some of
that culture sometimes we've had to go
along to get along sometimes you've had
to you know make compromises in order to
get the work done and black panther is
there's no compromises in that
specificity like that is the the
blackest thing I've ever seen and not in
a and not even say bad way like Luke
Cage was previously the blackest thing
I've ever seen but that was a black I
recognized like that was a black that
I'd seen before that was a street-level
we're in Harlem there's black people
those gangsters as crime this whatever
what calm is the dream what kind is the
the fairytale it's the it's the
neverland that black kids never get to
dream about and and that experience of
being there with all these guys and
ladies and women and children who had
all been kind of wanting that was was
incredibly powerful but I managed to put
my finger on what that thing was that I
felt like I was missing which was I
would ask people who was their favorite
character and nobody would ever say to
Chawla nobody would ever be like no that
that thing that he did that one time was
amazing no it's always remember in the
[ __ ] Busan casino when a coin flips
her wig at that dude amazing remember
that scene when sure he's like what are
those amazing like there were scenes
that everybody got to have that just
popped with people every time two
challahs on screen with another
character that character steals the
scene and you know nobody steals a scene
from Indiana Jones
nobody stills a scene from James Bond
nobody steals the scene from shaft you
know like those guys are the Centers of
those stories in a very real way and for
me to chala was the center that didn't
hold a black panther and as and I loved
the movie I can't get it I've seen it
three times again I love the movie but
I'm it took me a little while to start
to wrestle with why I was not feeling
the way I expected to be feeling about
it it was because I didn't love to chala
as much as I wanted to and part of it is
because he doesn't really want anything
in this movie like two challahs
narrative drive is hey I'm King right
this is awesome
my dad did a bad thing one time I didn't
catch claw I'm King again yay you know
like that's that is his sort of
narrative arc of that movie and it's
he's not driven by anything he doesn't
really want anything and he has no flaws
T'Challa is like Indiana Jones if he
wasn't afraid of snakes it's just he's
perfect and perfection is not dramatic
perfection is not you don't have the
tension of will his lesser demons over
ways greater angels will he succumbed to
his fatal flaws will he be weak when he
needs to be strong and you never got the
feeling for a second that de chollet
would not be what he is you never
thought he would give up you never
thought like I'm going to you ancestral
plane and I'm gonna confront my dad I'm
like you know what's cool that's fine
I I did what I need to do maybe I don't
know kill marker seems like a [ __ ] but
hey like that could have happened in a
weird way or at least the the the story
did not press us to the place where we
thought that the child would never do
that and it doesn't alleviate my love
for the movie to recognize that that for
me there's there's a there's a hero
problem there's often a hero problem
when you have a character who's that
noble who's that upstanding who's that
you know committed to tradition and and
maintaining the wakandan way of life but
I just wanted a little bit more and then
I sort of third time and the third time
I took my son we went we went Friday
like I pulled him out of school a little
bit early don't tell his mother he's a
little bit sick whatever and so I went
to go see with him and and we get ten
minutes into the movie and I cried like
a [ __ ] baby in a way that I hadn't
cried at all before we got to the point
in the movie where they're flying the
Royal Talon fighter back to a condo for
the first time and and akoi is sitting
there and she says we are home and the
home rekt me because I when you think of
home when you think of the concept of
what home means you know more often than
not it is where I grew up it's you know
it's where all my [ __ ] is it's it's
where home is and then when you start
drilling down into what that means in
the idea of a connection to a place and
a connection to a people who know who
you are from that place you know sure I
was born in the Bronx and I can go back
to the Bronx and maybe somebody will
have remembered me and I can I can my
father was born in Haiti and so there's
a world in which I could go back to
Haiti and I've done that and found a
bunch of cousins I never met but we're
not from Haiti you know like my mother's
parents are not from Trinidad or
Barbados they're from someplace else
that I don't know and I could do the DNA
work and I can do the [ __ ] genealogy
tests and all of that stuff and maybe
find a region in a continent that I can
maybe point to and say that my people
are from there but it's not the same as
being like an Italian who can point to a
village in Sicily and say oh no we were
there for hundreds of years or a Chinese
person who came like nah we were outside
the Guanzhong province and if I go there
there's thousands of years that I can
kind of trace my I know I can point to a
place and say that that place is mine
and african-americans by and large don't
have that place and the idea that
Wakanda is this almost impressionistic
version of but what if there was that
place what if that what if you could
have a place that you called home you
know when I started thinking about my
son he was getting to the age we starts
asking questions about identity and
about you know heredity and about you
know legacy and where he's from and who
his people are and and I also think
about like you know when he was a kid
it's all right when do we tell him that
the Santa Claus is a myth when we tell
him that the tooth fairy's not showing
up when do we when do we decide to abuse
him of the sort of childhood fantasies
that we were totally cool with you know
like let him believe in the magic let
him believe in the fakery let him
believe in in in the things we know
aren't real but they're pleasant
fictions and there's nothing wrong with
a nice Pleasant fiction and then it was
like why can't what con to be that
Pleasant fiction for a bunch of kids
who've never had to ask that question
before who've never four bunch of
parents who've had to sit there with
children and try and explain to them
what 400 years of slavery has done to
the identity of a
in entire people let him have a condo
let Wakanda be that for him and it
that's the thing that affected me the
most profoundly this was a movie that
attempted to fill a void that I didn't
even really recognize was there until it
filled it for me was the but what if it
was like this
wouldn't it have been amazing you know
like that's for me that's the hard work
that this movie does and it's not it's
not work that's done yet it's not work
that's over yet but just the idea that
you can create a piece of fiction a
piece of culture that fields as real as
that does that feels has lived in as
that does and you give characters who
all have motivations that for one an
agency except for one you know and then
it's an inherently feminist story I mean
you get to the end of that movie and the
climax is oh here's like three bad dudes
all at the tip of the spear of three
women standing over them you know the
best warriors in this entire fictional
place are female you know and you get
the sense that Ryan Coogler like lots of
black dudes was raised with her
incredibly strong mother in his house
you know and his mother was the one who
set the rules and set the tone and when
he did bad [ __ ] at school she was all
too punished him like and so for him
even behind the scenes his director
photography was a woman is costume
design was woman his design director was
a woman his editor was a woman like thee
they will make this better I am good at
this but they will make it great and
what Conda is the sort of the the the
the combination of that idea that we can
make it good they will make it great and
and this movie it is two things it is
what it is and it's what it means and
what it is is pretty [ __ ] great but
what it means is Titanic what it means
is is tectonic it shifts plates it will
it will reform the way Hollywood begins
to think about culture begin to think
about movies because the thing about the
people who get to tell their stories you
know the the the first numbers the Box
Office estimates came in and it made
something like 213 million dollars over
the four-day weekend and that's just
domestic in four days that made that
much money it took Justice League ninety
days
to make that much money.what black
panther didn't for its of Justice League
three months now not not that I want to
be the dude just [ __ ] rolling out
else to DC like hey [ __ ] you but but the
idea that if you let somebody tell their
story and if you know what that story is
the people will show up the audience
will respond they will they will embrace
the idea that even though none of these
people look like me even though this
place is fake even though all of this is
invented drama if it feels real if it
feels like the story behind if it feels
like the themes that it's touching on
are founded in some emotional truth
people respond to that the same way they
responded to Wonder Woman I mean one
moment it's not a perfect movie even
when one falls off a cliff in the third
act but for an hour and ten minutes that
movie feels like it's the movie patty
jen has been waiting her life to make
and she got the resources to do it she
convinced people to believe in her she
convinced them to do [ __ ] they didn't
want to do like it still pains me to
think that nobody wanted to do the no
man's land sequence until patty Jenkins
like dug her heels in was like no I
believe this is what the movies about
this scene is why we're making this
movie and if you don't do this let's
just stop and she won that fight and we
get a movie and we get we get some of
the changes the course of lives you know
we get we get seven year old girls who
suddenly think that you know what I can
dig in my heels you know what I am worth
as much if not more than anybody else
here you know and you look at Black
Panther and there's you know young black
kids is young black boys and black girls
young black girls who want to go into
science young black boys who have a
girlfriend that they are should be more
afraid of like all of these things
but they get texture and they get they
get agency and they get they get to
exist in a way they have in before so I
remain a little conflicted about the
movie you know I have I have thoughts on
how one fixes that movie because I'm
that guy who who is unwilling to leave
well enough alone but I I love that it
exists I love that it's doing as well as
it's doing I love that it gets so much
[ __ ] right because I mean it's almost
unheard of to get as much right as this
movie gets right and the fact that it's
it's operating at such a high level on
such a grand plane is it is it is a you
know how lucky we are to be alive right
now
so that is that it's gonna be my review
for now I mean I will get to more later
but I want to introduce the panel who
we've invited to come in and talk about
Black Panther they're hiding on the
background there hey stop talking yeah I
know you come this way
[Applause]
all right so I have four guests today
I'm not sure who's in front but uh okay
yes come this way
this is at Kayla Cooper he was a writer
producer on the cage he's got the show
running her first show for Netflix grab
a microphone come on this way this is
the time Morgan yay who was on both turn
Washington spies and into the badlands
who knows everything about [ __ ]
kungfu she will kick your ass but for
real Derek a Hughes who has been working
in genre TV since the 1940s most
recently on the flash black samurai
microphone in my hand it's [ __ ] up are
you taking my cue sent over there and
Evan Narcisse who is a culture writer
for io9 Kotaku and currently writing the
sold out in most places rise to the
black panther comic book for marvel so
everybody grab a mic and and i want to
talk about at the beginning just your
history with black panther like how much
did you guys bring to the movie how much
did you bring to the story personally i
was never a black panther stand as a kid
like I just wasn't I just did was I knew
of it I saw him as he crossed over and
intersected with a bunch of different
characters but I never read a black man
at the comic book until Tallahassee
started writing it so tell me about your
various and sundry experiences are you
[ __ ] up I would say same like I grew
up with a father who read comic books
it's why I'm a Marvel nerds like his
favorite was Thor oddly enough and then
I got into spider-man Iron Man and dead
as a kid so I was aware of Black Panther
just kind of on the periphery but I
never grew up like reading him as a
comic yeah I was definitely a Marvel kid
spider-man x-men represent but yeah I
only started reading it with time I see
you know Roxane gay for sure they were
great I think it was just a smattering
of black panther here and there you know
in the early 80s for me it was like I'd
see the I see the Kirby he was only
getting his battery yeah it was it
really was but it was just like I saw
the cat you know literally it was like
oh who's this guy and they saw then I
went through the Kirby books and you
know it was like I saw the stories in
there and you know his interactions with
the Fantastic Four and and then of
course Christopher priests run much
later it was though you know that was
kind of interesting but it never really
resonated with me other than just
knowing who to chala was knowing that
his inner involvement it always seemed
like he was an outsider in in more ways
than one so I never like actively sought
out black panther books you know other
than just questioning and like is he
ever going to get his own book get his
runs and stuff like that
and so again like when the Christopher
priest Ron came out you know I was like
I was I read it but I wasn't like into
it I thought it was interesting but for
whatever reason it just you know - yeah
it just never it was like it never it
never really was like okay I you know
he's changing my life but of course by
that time my life was already on
different things so yeah venire that
[ __ ] who every time somebody
asked me so tell me when did the door
Milosh a show up for the first time in
the comics I'm like ask Evan like dive
scholar you think of fandom as a
spectrum right and I don't consider
myself like like a deep end dude like I
know there's people out there who know
more than me but my thing like as a
critic and now as a writer of these
stories is like
do you use what you know like to answer
directly answer the question I've you
know to toss my favorite superhero since
I was a kid I can tell you the first
time I encountered the character and
then when it looked fell in love with
the character first time I read it was
like in a reprint of an old Avengers
series from like the 60s and 70s and
then I I read Don MacGregor as Panthers
pray series which I think was 95 it was
let's go with that it is drawn by Duane
Turner beautiful art then I went back
and looked at the other Tom MacGregor
stuff and he's a guy who really gave
T'Challa a soul and you know III
basically checked for T'Challa my entire
life I'm that dude who like shorts a
comic book shop scene issue daredevil
black panther on the cover like okay
well I guess I'm buying this even if I
wasn't buying daredevil at the time like
all the guest appearances I just held on
for so long for the child I get like his
own book and have somebody to like
really love him and take care of him and
that that person after MacGregor wanted
to being Christopher priest and that run
is I mean iconic and stellar and I'm a
huge priest and so don't get me started
so I've been involved with T'Challa like
most of my you know pre adult and adult
life and now I'm right in the comic
which is a whole other thing you are
right in the comment yeah I'm right yeah
[Applause]
I heard it's pretty awesome though I was
not a plan bit by the way like dreams
they do come true I know and what we
what was the everybody's feelings when
they first heard that a Marvel was gonna
do a black panther movie that's about
damn time
yeah don't [ __ ] it up because there's a
hundred ways that could have [ __ ] this
oh my god you know well that's the thing
though because like you know Wesley
Snipes had it back in the 90s and you
know back then it was very questionable
I mean look is Wesley Snipes but at the
same time there was there wasn't a
template for this right you know it's
like I was joking with a buddy of mine a
day I said Marvel basically has the
blueprint now they're like jay-z they
like they they're showing people like
this is the blue
print but other Studios keep [ __ ] up
and not following the blueprint and that
but at that time there was no blueprint
so it could have been a hundred minutes
you know different ways of like you know
like I said don't [ __ ] it up but when
they announced it it was like because it
was marble and knew that doing it by
that time I was like okay this is gonna
be it's gonna probably something special
yeah I remember debating with like
another friend of mine he was just like
it's never gonna happen it's never gonna
happen they're never gonna do it I'm
like you know there's phase 3 it might
they might get to us and then I was like
working on the they're gonna do a black
panther and it's chadwick boseman it was
like because like my top choices in like
fantasizing about it I was like I'd
always pictured oddly enough like my
Will Smith
no Michael B Jordan as a young to chala
every studio was Will Smith though no
for me was always chouet oh yeah it just
would have been bad either you know
that's the Idris Klaus you got to
consider any high-profile black starring
role well maybe the dukes of hazzard how
do we feel about addresses beau dude
[Laughter]
note to self
Dixie has his reboot with It Yourself oh
I had seen 42 at the time so I was like
yes that makes sense I am down with this
he's playing like every famous prairies
play every March that they're good so
why not not do i saw the joke that was
uh he's gonna wind up playing himself or
he's gonna play meryl streep
I was a little bit when they announced
that Kugler was gonna direct it I was
excited because I [ __ ] love Creed to
death I was a little concerned for him
in that we've all seen and heard about
directors who end up in the Marvel
machine
yeah and end up getting round up by the
moment machine and I'm like this
make two movies like when like let him
mature as an artist let him find his
footing let him make a bunch of [ __ ]
before he gets a 29 at the same argument
they use for Barack Obama yeah I wanted
him to have like the Spike Lee career
yeah like a 1 and a half just like a
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] under his belt
movies that meant everything to him just
hard make art for a decade like back up
the money truck yeah because they say
like it's gonna make a billion dollars
in less than three weeks and he's just
like yeah I can do anything
- it's not contracted for I mean I
remember hearing that announcement like
that d23 announcement and I guess I was
to look otaku at the time and you know I
had to kind of pitch my head I was like
look we should hit this like this is
gonna be huge so let me do it I remember
riding up like I think the headline of
the piece was like Marvel's phase threes
movies are gonna be their riskiest and
most important ones yet and like I gave
myself a migraine that day because it
was just like how do I communicate the
pressure of how how much they need to
get black panther right like Captain
Marvel yes they I mean obviously there's
a lot of pressure that but like for me
from a personal perspective it was like
they really can't [ __ ] up black panther
like they can't like it's your one shot
to be like okay we get y'all don't [ __ ]
it up I was the only one who was not
afraid that he when he was announced
that he was gonna take the reins I was
happy you know I was nothing like studio
money yeah I was like oh my god the
machines gonna chew him up I thought the
bravado that was in Creed was so
fantastic and so amazing that if they
were gonna tap him to do black panther
that they were gonna put the right team
around him the one scene and Creed that
made me feel like Ryan could do it
was one shot come on now the single come
on the Hair Braiding actually for me cuz
that's like an actual that's such an
important scene because it's like that
shows care between characters and really
intimate way and it's something that you
know you have to know black people to
know like that how that [ __ ] goes down
and then maybe feel like okay you can
communicate this on the screen so that
made me feel like it was like similar to
when I saw Kiss Kiss Bang Bang that yeah
Shane Black movie with Robert Downey jr.
built Valkyrie Iron Man yeah yeah but
like oh like he could like play some
like super bravado
you know cocky you know intricately like
[ __ ] up character like that made me
feel like he could do it so that was the
same thing I remember I was I did a
roundtable for the holiday Porter like
three years ago I think and I was
talking about sort of racing Hollywood
as oscarssowhite and whatever and and
Justin Simien Alan yang Stephanie Lane
were on the panel I voiced my my tiny
concern that I was just hoping that Ryan
would get more time to be an artist and
want Ryan to be Ryan and Justin means
everything don't [ __ ] worry about
Ryan Ryan's gonna be fine I mean it's
it's the thing is the the great
achievement of this movie is that like
he made a personal movie that's also
super movie like it's yeah so let's talk
about the movie we've all seen it
right some of this multiple times real
quick I just like that I want to put
this out there because I have to give
props also the Joe Robert Cole because
there's been so many think pieces
talking about Ryan Coogler but my man
and Joe started it you know it's like it
starts on the page and as a writer it's
like it's it's irritating when we get
ignored and it's like especially you
know in features right it's like like
they think it just magically happens
like the director comes into like his
story
and it's just like you know not to take
anything away from Ryan cuz yes he did
put his blood sweat and tears into it
but you know it's the other part of that
equation was definitely chill cold I had
a chance to meet Joe at the yeah to
premiere and he's a really cool dude
yeah and like he's super thoughtful and
it's funny cuz they're both really
thoughtful yes like so you can see how
like already people who are like ready
to like figure out the logic of this
world and these characters like putting
their heads together like you might
reach conversations with him let me
figure out like okay yeah you had like
an integral part in this yeah I think
didn't he work on the People vs OJ is
great nuance with character so skip was
in good hands I also think he was like
part of the Marvel writers yes
standalone Falcon like got killed but
then they're like no it was actually a
war machine Oh war machine yeah yeah
that's probably back up what about that
character Monica Rambeau
what's she doing what's he up to where's
the storm movie I'm waiting on that yes
although for my moment
Disney buys Fox yeah I think you do
because I think if I'm Disney right now
if I'm Marvel right now and I know that
our DJ is gonna at some point phase out
of this yeah somebody rereading an armor
not even [ __ ] Sheree sure don't even
read me that [ __ ] because I love RiRi
Williams I'm on top of that but Marvel
do like how many people in the real
world know Reba Williams and now how
many people know sugary that's true it's
sure reread well sure that's our Oakland
moniker sure Erie Williams well the one
that I'm waiting on and you know really
see you know hopeful that they're gonna
announce it in their phase 4 is Kamala
Khan yeah they're over dude they're so
overdue yeah right yeah yeah so yeah the
movie III have waxed already about how I
feel about the movie how we didn't hear
it we were I notice he did that without
I feel like a colonizing so no tell me
what you guys thought I love ya I just
came from seeing it for the fourth time
today so wow you got me beat this I've
seen it three times I mean I've loved it
every time I've seen it like I've you
know the first time I saw it was like
super emotional
I mean I'm coming at this from multiple
vectors I've been a fan my entire life
you know I wrote about Black Panther as
a critic and how important the
characters been to me
and writing this series and like they
just got me right in the bag so at the
premiere like literally from the first
line I'm like falling baba tell me a
story tell me about but then the second
time I started a press screening in
Austin and I think a you're cool you got
to let it out right you're good you're
good you keep it together and again like
just do the dance like waterfalls like
so yeah I loved it like you know it's it
it's it like I'm gonna take his movie
like vitamins like as often as possible
brah I wanted a real quick I was like I
walked out the theater I was like I
gotta shave my head it's like I'm gonna
get a spirit I don't care there was no
man but you know what when that came on
in the club I was like break it down a
boy like taking a backseat dude
everything is so like when the trailer
came out I was just like yes I get to
see someone who looks kind of like me
but it's not necessarily my gender
because when the trailer for Wonder
Woman came out and I saw Wonder all I'm
like this is fun but like wait not me
but then when the Black Panther trailer
drop I was like oh you start seeing like
the Dorma logic I'll call you a kicking
ass okay so there are at least be a
scene of like a black woman kicking ass
in that movie and then I see the movie
and it's like there are multifaceted
black women in this movie kicking ass I
mean we're so good big ammo like having
dip it was just I was just shot and so
appreciate I'm like I actually don't
kind of have to take a back seat I can
enjoy this on multiple levels and it was
wonderful
yeah and it wasn't just in front of the
camera either it was behind the scenes
as well you had a great DP Rachel
Morrison you had the costume designer
Ruth Carter who was Hannah Beach it was
just such strong women on screen and
behind the camera as well yeah I
remember seeing that there's that scene
in the trailer I mean they said the
trailers in the movie it's everywhere
when that Royal shuttle first bursted
there yeah yeah and if you look at the
[ __ ] like the blaster the whatever
the the engine glow from the back of it
there's African symbols Morpheus pulsing
back and forth I'm like they spent money
on that somebody's I'm yeah that's that
cheap that's expensive
yeah it could just be Millennium Falcon
blue and that'd be fine right no it's
got to be like
Kinta cloth yes go for it yeah yeah now
I
speak a little bit about where I felt
the movie didn't quite work for me my
I'm calling it the T'Challa problem you
don't speak I would remind you
[ __ ] this is my house
glory to Allah I mean my problem was as
I told the people if you weren't
listening about whatever is that
T'Challa
whenever he's on screen with anybody
else is the least interesting person on
screen his story is incredibly OneNote
in a way which is hey ten minutes in I'm
King you know it'd be awesome if I was
king I'm still King King was awesome oh
[ __ ] I'm not King King again like he
he's not driven as king by title but
he's not in it mentally there because
even when he confesses to his father he
says I don't know if I can do this
without you do this slow things down but
I also think his journey is like it's
like what kind of king is going to be
and like do I follow in the ancestors
footsteps and his choice at the end is
like no [ __ ] that like we we clearly
need a change yeah I mean those I I get
the cerebral Moo yeah yeah but like the
only thing he like the Ark of the
Covenant for him in that movie exists
for like ten minutes and that's claw
claw I'm gonna go to [ __ ] casino and
blow it because you know to get clogged
and I [ __ ] that up but that's all he
really wants that's the only object
that's driving him in the scenes he's
very active yes for the rest of the
movies he's a passive character I mean
you go there you go
as I say he's not so much a passive
character because he's reactive to the
fact that the sins of his father and now
throw a step on yeah yeah I mean that's
what Eric hill mongers you know it's
because of his father's actions and you
know I think he wants justice which is
not to sound corny but like he he was
justice in a way that for me was really
powerful for like when he's talking to
his dad on the airplane a second time
he's like why need you bring the boy
home and I felt that [ __ ] in my chest
like like I like that was like real
outrage and then you know I feel like
him wanting to right that wrong was the
thing that that that animates the back
half of the movie or live at the last
third of the movie like I felt like he
wanted that like in the whole world
upside down because what what I know but
that's seen when they're all like laying
on hands to try to bring him back to
your dad that was like that was very
emotion that was very I kept wanting I
kept wanting jury and I'm sorry what's
your face like remonda
to be adora like I wanted her at the end
of the motion she was put on armor
yes like can you keep my mom here can
you keep her safe to [ __ ] you yeah I
mean
it's got American Horror Story in
nine-one-one she got to take a break at
some points but she was hey speaking of
real quick about Angela Bassett there
was a moment without watching and
there's like please just let her lift up
her arms and summon a rain cloud I was
like come on let's do it just go ahead
and do it but she hadn't won so we're
never going to do Jabari lands and the
Kea comes up with Ross that ring blade
you play whoo - [ __ ] you yeah she was
ready to go so I mean I feel like the
movie was serviced a lot by little grace
notes like that that lets you know like
there's that one exchange between Sheree
and T'Challa in the lab and she's like
you know not like your suit your design
that let you know that okay right you
know he's so scientists he can still
build [ __ ] he's so hot [ __ ] you know but
she's just better said in that like that
little rapport between it was like I
think if I said she's the smartest
character in the Marvel Universe Martin
Tony Stark yes yeah sixteen years old so
now what do you guys think happens going
forward what do you think this does in
Hollywood what and both on a macro level
and on a personal level like how does
this I'm curious to see how people are
gonna dress for the Oscars I mean it's
funny I've been asked about I've been
doing a lot of interviews this past
month about Black Panther [ __ ] and I've
been saying that my constant refrain has
been I just want black creators in
Hollywood to have decision-making power
and trust in leeway like you know like
this this yeah crap for that
like this this this movie happens
because Ryan like had a vision Ryan and
Joe and all their creative team had a
vision they executed on it was Marvel
involved sure Nate Warren Lamar besides
a producer who shepherded this project
into being a great guy you know but like
ultimately you can feel the trust in
this movie it feels personal you know
like get you back to Oakland like like
literally and figuratively one of the
questions I always have to answer is
it's a black panther superhero have any
connection to the Black Panther Party
and you know it's inconclusive
right but what Ryan did and everybody
did on that movies like they made it
explicit like guess what yeah black
empowerment black self-determination
self-love like all that black panther
[ __ ] that from the real world is
connected to their character now and
that's like essentially Canon like
millions of people's brains and that's
an amazing thing I want more of that
happen even though even the historical
stuff with a Jobu right it's like he'd
the fact that he was the reason why he
was raising that army in the first place
was because it was 1992 yeah at the same
time is the riot
right right right and it so is like he
saw it with firsthand of like what was
going on at that time and that's why you
know so automatically you already
understand his his point of view you
know was it right that's questionable
right but there is a point of view and
it just you know it made the world shape
that world so it didn't feel like it was
something that was wrought by committee
yeah yeah I will never put it past like
a studio executive till I keep their
head in the sand but like I tweeted
about this earlier today it's like Luke
Cage broke netflix the Saturday it
premiered was it moonlight won best
picture girls trip made over a hundred
million dollars and it was an r-rated
comedy starring for black women and now
Black Panther has sailed past like 200
million domestically something like 300
million worldwide almost 230 by tomorrow
apparently yes
[Applause]
you can't ignore this if your goal is we
have a product and this product needs to
make money there's an entire cash flow
over here that you've been ignoring and
we're just like no we have money and we
want to see stories that represent us so
give us that it will give you our money
it's simple [ __ ] financial math I
mean the product the tricky thing here
is that this is not an easy easily
replicable formula right like you need a
what Kaunas just ain't sitting around
out there to be made into [ __ ]
multi-million dollar movies like and
even for Marvel like if they want to if
they want to replicate this formula
they're gonna have to like figure some
[ __ ] out a lot of disappoint people
trying to find their way to flick on
that this summer Donald Trump be like
hey so how what conned in the u.s.
relations going yeah you know he doesn't
know it's not a fake place right no I
think to every everything doesn't have
to be black panther I'm glad that it
exists it's a huge movie and it's
amazing the numbers that is done but I
hope he just as happy as if Netflix who
is throwing money at all kinds of stuff
would do a hundred moon lights you know
what I mean they have a hundred million
dollars to throw around to give to some
people so why not
I mean look guys shout out to Black
Lightning again yeah oh that was another
one where they allowed the creators be
able to really tell the story and really
deliver on a level that has just raised
the bar over there at the CW and you
know it's like what what was irritating
was like last year when get out came out
right phenomenal movie right we can all
agree on that right Jordan black kill
I'm not George black Jordan Peele yeah
you know actually I have a friend named
George black it
and it's like and Jordan Peele killed it
and you know it's like but it was that
notion of like well you know it was only
a four million dollar movie and you know
it's they treat it as a fluke like oh
you know well it was just the timing of
it and it's a horror movie and people
just wanted to see that and then they
and then it's back to business as usual
you know girls trip
girls trip makes over a hundred million
dollars but you know it's like well
that's that's just that movie you know
just happen to have Tiffany Haddish and
they have this you know and it has Jada
Pinkett and they treat it like these
flukes it's like this time around they
can't treat it like a fluke there's no
way the make the excuse of like the old
excuses of like well it doesn't do well
internationally black films don't do it
you know it's like this what we can't
market them you know it's like I would I
would love to believe that absolutely I
will say the boy changes us
what's avatar made two hundred seventy
nine billion billion million dollars yes
they were not green lighting original IP
from strong creative minds even
advancing technology it was still let's
do another sequel to this right it was
because it was still James Cameron
success even monumental success yeah
Hollywood is always afraid of doing the
thing that feels a little bit different
don't even have any sense of comfort in
and the idea I mean I would love for
this to mean and not we get a hundred
Black Panthers no but that you get
creators of diverse backgrounds who get
to tell their story yes and those
stories could also be featuring white
people yes I don't think I've ever seen
right I wouldn't mind but I don't need
well you know I'm working on a
screenplay called Fanta black so you
know it's gonna be just black black
black people and it's gonna be on black
pages black leather it's just it's like
without oh well we got more blab like
it's like Coco last year it's a
beautiful movie hyper specific yeah yeah
you know and and we've talked about it a
lot online and in person the idea that
cultural specificity specificity breeds
universality yeah the idea that like
this means something to this person and
they've they found the ways to dig into
the nooks and crannies and they found a
ways to make it alive and that means
that other people can find their way
into it too when I saw a black panther
for the second time I saw with two
friends one Mexican and one Filipino and
and and the Filipino woman was saying it
yeah like she was crying too if you are
living in a predominantly white
environment if you are from somewhere
else and you have these feelings of
dissonance with your home culture of
broken history of not knowing how to
seat yourself in the legacy in the
history that spawned you like that's
universal like Brian went at that very
culturally specific feeling he had about
his own black identity in relation to
Africa made a movie about it and then
the specificity of it led become
universal and like you know the fact
that there is you know dozens hundreds
of variations of that kind of story out
there it's like super exciting that's
for I would say I will say this one last
thing about that it's like my friend Y
got kid is about seven or eight years
old he was just telling me the other day
that you know I took this kid to see
Black Panther and now he's like clear
the slate like everything is black
panther you know all the toys every like
that you know and it's like it's so
great to hear that there's like that
this kid is pouring himself into that
role of black panther and not
questioning like well he's a black guy
can't do that it's the same way that
we've done it cuz like the first comic
book I read was a spider-man comic when
I was seven years old and I dreamed
about moving to New York and being just
like Peter Parker you know and not
stopping to think of broke all the time
[ __ ] up girlfriend
I had I had I had a dream that I was
gonna live in Soho I had no idea what
Soho was it was it's not in Queens oh
yeah you know it was like and I'ma you
know you know I'm gonna chill over at
Central Park again having no idea and
then I'm gonna work at Marvel you know
as they but the the idea that you know
we've had to do that you know like from
things like again spider-man et you know
all these things that were rapport we
see ourselves as those characters but
never stopping to think about like well
they don't look like me and just like
well I can relate to them there's still
kids there's still this and now we have
a generation that is actually seeing
this on the screen larger than life
that's representing a black superhero
but again they're seeing it the same way
that we've always felt and you know I
think that's you know fantastic this
came out like a couple weeks ago or
maybe like over Christmas but it was win
I guess Target or something had released
their black panther toy set and they
released the and their white friend
playing in their backyard pretending to
be Black Panthers like I've never had
that as a kid yeah my car my colleague
Charles pulling him or wrote a piece
about that because he was like its
commercial like I know maybe we
shouldn't be blogging about a commercial
but I cuz he's like this is what I
wanted when I was a kid ya know like the
fact that hopefully our kids will not be
wanting for this is significant
representation matters yes it really is
so
four out of five of us working
television we work in Hollywood actively
sorry Evan that's all good I write
comics yeah how do you think this is
going to impact your kind of day-to-day
work in how do you how do you think you
listen you cannot shout down every white
person in every room you want to be
alone with that you like got my back
like how people are we treating their
black colleagues and work come tomorrow
you know it's like how they go you know
it's like at like the day after Obama
won everybody was like how you doing or
something else more culturally specific
there's a there's that meme that's
floating around with a Bradley from get
out saying you know I seem like is this
the time when everybody shows Dustin off
there's I can't here's my super black
thing that I have it's time to go pitch
this [ __ ] well something I noticed it
was starting after get out last year
what I would have liked do development
stuff like I had two projects where like
the pod like the producer only whatever
that D stands for was basically like
pitching me something that like I had
read on the page it's like when you
don't have like a racial description of
the main character I was like okay
they're probably white but then they
were like actually no it's like we're
looking to cast like a black woman for
this or a black lead for this in a way
oh you're bringing this to me I don't
have to like tell oh oh that's fun
riding a spec feature now that like has
interest and so like normally I'd have
been like okay I'm going to like
politely suggest maybe you make the lead
character play now I'm just like you
know you can make money off of this if
it's a black lead right right you met
with some Duke so yeah it's like I don't
I feel like having started in this
business something like like 14 years
ago it was always the thing where I was
like I'm gonna do that Shawna thing
where I'm gonna like create a show with
a white lead so that like my next show I
can like have the power trickily the one
for them one literally it has black
people in it deal with it
buy it please yeah I feel like there's
definitely a temperature change where
people are more receptive to having
ideas they would have with people of
color I know in my network I brought
them a book for something about the
black lives matter movement that I
talked to them about soft pitch them and
I was like you've never done anything
like this on your network ever before
but this is something that I'm
interested in and they were game so I
think the tides are changing excellent
all right listen I think it's time to
open this up to the room like I'm sure
you guys all have feelings and thoughts
and dreams and earlier actually
neighboring nation of Wakanda
we all know Everett Ross and claw has a
buddy that's true
give me the you mean the Betty that has
the sound the sound cloud link yeah how
come the internet hasn't done that yet
made the sound cloud League of clouds
like someone needs to do like a take
that and break it off mixtape right
cause mixtape come on internet don't let
me down look there's a lot of influence
you know of Reggie Hudlin brian Stelter
ease you know Christopher priest I mean
it's like Tana hi-c codes
he's like Jonathan Hickman Jonathan
Hickman yep it's it's you know and you
can see all of that come together but
that's Marvel they know how to make that
stew is
[Music]
maybe they think he's having a bad day
like maybe not as bulletproof
maybe maybe forgot this one we had that
conversation in the room as well new
manga was right it may be a little less
genocide yeah
the woman killing two he like killed
adore Miller saying that he's a
liberator but actually he's a bit
selfish because it was all selfish
ambitions that were played by the door
yo also also that I haven't seen it but
I diss my theory I was like he's
freaking Bruce Wayne without the money
it's like it's like he did you know he
didn't have the privilege and so it's
like and this is what would happen to
Bruce Wayne is like he had to because
he's just as crazy but it's also Nakia
let's not lighten the kids you know what
she was saying that she from the
beginning Nakia was right that is true
everybody but the child was right but
it's too dad
visit help nurture us we got a brother
holding up his arm it's hurt them so
you're welcome
a question would be awesome we can do
now we gonna do now
make movies right was a joke
he's the film student there
[Music]
yeah I'm at [ __ ] Locksley okay I am
also a notorious crier so it doesn't
take that much not even choices Kevin is
because Kevin will cry at the and the
closing of a giant container yeah I mean
there's there's there's nothing but sort
of metaphor in deep meanings and
parallels and resonances in the movie
you know even even that bit at the end
when when when kill monger spoilers has
a spear in his chest and he's you know
he's looking at it what content he's
like you know to think that a kid from
Oakland could ever dream yes of
something of a fairy tale just just the
idea that that so many black kids so
many black adults so many adults period
are not allowed to indulge their dreams
because you know there's the exigencies
of the world like you've got to pay
bills you got to do whatever you got to
get [ __ ] done that doesn't leave enough
time for you to dream anymore and yes
there's a super metaphor that like Ryan
Coogler is also a kid from Oakland who
decided to like raise himself up and
believe in dreams and make this [ __ ]
thing happen like this is that we're
watching the texture the tapestry of his
dreams writ large like that's super
powerful but even just for yourself like
still believe in the dreams you know
still don't don't ever let them go
because those at the end of the day are
the fuel that will help you do all the
other [ __ ] that you got to do the things
you go oh ya know that was the exact
line for me that like got me tearing up
it's like you know a kid from Oakland
run around believing in fairy tales like
I'm a kid from a very small town in
Missouri who would like look around it
farm Lee Anne in dream of like moving to
Los Angeles in making movies and I'm
like you should get to see the
is he dead
let's see I was I grew up just outside
of co-op city ah there it is so for me
for me like the like super resonators
start with a friend a black friend on
Thursday and they keep asking who are
you what's your name
like cuz then you the name you would add
had you stay it on the continent it's
not the name you have now and and like
that's why it's so jarring when the
Isaac to be cold character and with the
lip lip plate says he sees you what is
your name
like cuz like that's and that goes to
like deep fairytale mythology [ __ ] the
truth the power of the true name right
like I know your real name and that like
and again with all that kind of black
diaspora dynamics going on around that
[ __ ] like was really meaningful again
it's like the scene I mentioned before
that warrior Falls show him who you are
like this idea that the world as it is
has obfuscated our true selves and and
disconnected them from our histories
like it's super [ __ ] powerful
everything in the astral plane really
had me jacked up I mean first of all I
was shot so beautifully it just looked
gorgeous but there was one line in
particular when he goes in the first
time and he sees his father and he's
like holding his hand he's down on his
knees and he says stand you are a king
and I was like I just I just cried I was
like oh my god I think that was the
message for everyone stand you are royal
you are king real quick to bring it home
though it's like what what you know
brought at home was at the end when
T'Challa and Sheree in an oh they're in
Oakland and they're open up the first
what Conda Outreach Center you know and
it's like so he brought you know he
brought the help he like he listened and
he's like I'm he
and you know I'm starting here and it's
like and it was like one of those
powerful moments like oh snap first
world nation coming to a third-world
nation to help them out
[ __ ] we're the third-world nation I mean
as a quick aside there's a it's a
question I've had to deal with in
writing rise in a black panther like
what cons is there right like how come
y'all [ __ ] with the outside world you
know some of the reasonings are are
similar to what's been said in the movie
but there's a scene between T'Challa and
I'm a ver major Marvel villain where
that question gets raised and tautology
has to give an answer is it Howard the
Duck what you got man
okay this was for me it's for all of us
but you get what I want
because I saw my character point thank
you
I mean I just wrote named Warren
T'Challa an issue to arise little black
panther and that [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] fun like dude oil and
water literally like coconut oil and
Siwon its parrot they're so fun because
yeah people are like they're both kings
and they're both superheroes but now the
thing about like name war is talks mad
[ __ ] talk so much [ __ ] super strong he's
like he's been long alive longer two
challahs like grandfathers like going
back several generations like and and
and just like you know he thinks surface
world like I wrote an insult in the
issue - it was a T'Challa Hughes name or
a [ __ ] around wakandan [ __ ] he's like
what do I care for the dusty lives a
surface folk it was just like dust for
an Atlantian must be the biggest insult
all over be what the [ __ ] anyway but
like - child is a complete polar
opposite right he's considered he's
strategic he's careful is compassionate
like I would love to have those two
characters in conflict in upcoming
Marvel movie
well you got it like you said that's a
big if because Fox is like no it's like
they're gonna hold on to as much as
possible I mean that's what you're just
talking about legal troubles and tangled
entanglement well they're all big one
happy now but it remains to be seen
say no to be yeah yeah no it's like say
I was I was going to throw one out there
I was going to tell us that Craven now
yes exactly
Kraven the hunter I think that there's
absolutely world in which Wakanda now
being unveiled to the world at large
will draw trouble from afar yeah and and
Craven I think there's a cast Hugh
Jackman nice because he's not busy but
yeah I just think there's there's a lot
to say about you know hunter versus prey
there's a lot of stuff to get into the
the your first real white villain in one
of these like claw isn't the villain in
any real way in this movie he's he's
henchman at best but to actually be able
to play with those idea of valuing life
and devaluing life and what is worth
what and I don't I just think there's a
lot of fun to be had I mean but hey
they've they are happy to play ball with
Disney as long as they keep making them
in spider-man movies so you guys named
all the big ones but I would say people
I want to see more of obviously more
adorable today but I would say I oh and
any good love story that was in Roxane
gay world Wakanda that completely got
skipped over there's room I would love
to see more of that in the next one the
great thing about that story is to give
you it gave you a different angle on the
monarchy like what do people actually
think about this dude it keeps on
leaving the country and getting involved
this [ __ ] yeah by bonus answer white
wolf like the character of hunter
widgets who I got oh yeah Bucky is here
so
why is he not like background of the lab
in in credits yeah it's like cause
frozen tube in the back like yeah they
kind of they kind of gave Eric hill
monger white wolfs back story it's like
so there's gonna be a different sort of
white wolf I mean I think that if he's
gonna be with a hot suit was the hot
sensor are proper to sera sera you know
that that he will be you know maybe sort
of like the elite force yeah but the
secret you know because like that's what
Bucky does best awesome a lot of more
[Music]
the for the time that I was there there
was some focus on the warrior pasta
there was a moment where after standing
Blazing Sun all day watching you know
kind of go back and forth there was just
like a moment everybody had stopped and
you know Ryan was doing wasn't working
I'm looking around and see just gonna
get it before the movie come out my
expectations were high but seeing these
people instead you know even as
[Music]
you know me I don't want to make
apologies for the film maybe he wanted
to like gain claws trust to the point
where like you know he could basically
cap them like that they have claws Gor
guard down I don't know yeah I mean I'm
I've been told there's like a 4-hour cut
of this movie somewhere yes and I need
that cut and I'm sure that in that cut
yeah for real
[ __ ] that's not a cut Google cut but it
but it feels as if there's there's
there's a world in which so much of that
story was kill manga does not know how
to get to a condom yes he doesn't have
the GPS yeah like he doesn't have the
map that we see in his dad's things
which is a really easy [ __ ] insert
shot to drop into a movie yeah to then
they help explain how he knows where
what Conda is yeah it feels like there
was probably that was a that was a long
cut for time all right yeah I just
assumed like once you pop claw you like
the homies iPad and was like oh okay
yeah I mean there's there probably was
another way to do it that would have a
probably listen to the sound cloud mix
to the Cape can we get back to the real
quick and I'm sorry I just need 47 times
you watched I was like how we touch and
he's a big dude I wish that a bigger
moment in the movie because like the
first time I missed that line and then I
caught it the second time it's like oh
that's right you would have known him
yeah I got that yeah [ __ ] you goes dog
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
by July I'm 3,000 miles away from my
parents so it's it's all hard for me to
just be like but my mom texted me like a
week and a half ago my mom who indulge
my nerdery is a kid but never really
embraced it it's one of those like
deeply these comic books cuz they're
getting everywhere I mean yeah trying to
take another space movie I can your
father do that but she texted me to be
like hey so have you seen Black Panther
yet now I am not living there to tell
her there's a Black Panther movie coming
out she's not inundated by it through me
I'm not her vector into Black Panther
but she knows and she knows to ask me if
I've seen it yet and I told her that I
haven't because I couldn't tell her that
I met Ava Duvernay at the premiere
because that would make her the most
jealous mom you've ever known there was
a time super sad that I was always
working at The Hollywood Reporter and we
did a cover story on Oprah and and and
Oprah worked the the open offices owned
was in the same building as a hunter
reporter so just one day she decides to
roll up on the office right so I died I
mean right right you can't just do that
unannounced
Oprah shows up at the office I haven't
closed the cover story the day before
took the day off and so I just see how
much
Media like all of the people working at
me and I can like track her through the
office [ __ ] won't buy my desk
why is everything shining a little bit
brighter oh my god I feel hoping I'm
Raven if you're lope and my mom was like
so here Oprah was in your office did you
meet her no you had one job your one job
was to meet Oprah and tell her that you
mean everything to your mother so
Thanksgiving and Christmas is canceled
this year savings bonds so Joe well
[Music]
that's his Kryptonian name Joe my
parents divorced when I was really young
I didn't grow old my dad and we're like
you know we've kind of remediated our
relationship a little bit and as things
have kind of ramped up with the movie
semi coinciding with the issues of this
comic book coming out and I did a
signing in New York City on January 19th
and some people I was expecting to come
my dad showed up I didn't go with him I
didn't know the extent to which that he
knew what I did or cared whatever like
we're friendly but like you know you
don't have to be like a black panther
nerd to like get into that [ __ ] but he
showed up to get a comic book sign like
that I wrote and like he did that
because this movie exists and and and he
knows what it means like not just for me
like it means something for him too
and that I mean
20:18 has been really really was surreal
for me you took it to the astral plane
yes
speaking of like I actually talked to my
mom earlier today cuz she's still back
home in Missouri and I had actually
offered to fly her out this weekend so
she could see it with me and my friends
and she was just like no no it's okay
you don't have to spend the money I'm
like but I will be hounding you to see
this movie when it comes out cuz
normally should just wait til stuff
comes out on video I'm like no you can't
do that no and so she she saw today and
she called me she's like I love it it
was so good
and she grew up in the segregated south
and she was just like I really like kill
mugger I feel so bad when he died I wish
you had died are they are they gonna
bring him back like they can bring him
back like her whole thing was like
low-key she was like they can bring him
back right I'm like they're probably not
bring you back but she was like no like
she really identified with his last line
or he was like bear me in the ocean with
my ancestors but for me it was like for
the ancestral plane of it all like again
like my dad was a Marvel nerd who raised
me on comic books and action movies and
he died like two and a half years ago so
for me for all of these movies it's been
like Shh he's not here he's not here to
see this and like his favorite character
was Thor in like Thor egg I was crawling
in thor ragnarok because they finally
got his favorite character right and he
wasn't there to see it and then for this
it's just like son of a [ __ ] so when
they were on the astral plane
enchanted because like that's not what I
was talking about it's like I don't know
how to live without you I'm like I'm not
gonna do it I'm not gonna cry I tear it
up and like I tried to do that discrete
thing where I'm like but yes like my mom
loved in for me was just like I wish my
dad could have seen this cuz like I know
just from the stories that he told me
growing up in this again in the
segregated south as a kid like he went
through some [ __ ] and I know he would
have appreciated this movie
all right I told my mom I thought my mom
I'm like look I know you know since
you're Japanese this one ain't for you
so you know but since I'm working on a
samurai project you know when that comes
out we'll Thor and Hulk look think about
how long you've been waiting
we've been waiting to see a Black
Panther movie to see black glory as
marked so brilliantly coined it in a PC
wrote like you think we ain't been
waiting that long you know like it's
overdue yeah and to that point I would
say it's like it shouldn't be something
because I think there's a controversy
with the movie that Ocoee and no I oh
and flirting we're going to be in the
four-hour cutting so but it's like again
like that would have just been a moment
that anyone could have read anyway and I
feel like if they're gonna do it they
need to [ __ ] do it
mmm and like had the relationship and
not like tiptoe around it so that they
can sell it to you know conservative
countries overseas yeah it is that it is
that long road though right it's like
it's like memmer back in the day when
the Wesley Sneijder was when it was just
was the one was it dropped in the drop
zone or those passenger 57 or whatever
it was the one where he basically was
with the auntie but Lee remember and it
was like again all the way to the end of
the movie and it was you know normally
heroes supposed to kiss the girl she
leans her head on his chest
like we can't have that black man
concern a white woman it's just like
it's not gonna happen you know and and
it's sort of that that that sort of
hesitation that you see you know and and
people keep trying to push it but
there's still people that are in charge
that feel like it's all about that
bottom dollar and they're feeling
nervous and you know skittish and it's
gonna take somebody that's gonna say
like no absolutely not we're going to
actually have that moment in there
whether you like it or not happen
because Valkyrie in thor ragnarok was
supposed to have been bisexual and there
was a scene in there with i guess it's
like the chick who she's watching died
yeah and like that sins are on her
bender like that was supposed to have
been her girlfriend and they cut that
scene yeah but if they're gonna do it I
feel like they should actually do it and
not just do it like a drive-by like
whatever like they should actually have
it be a real kiss my scene
a little story like service it is what
they should do I mean I think that that
Marvel has put themselves in that pretty
unique position in that we will watch
whatever they do no matter what like I'm
there there was a world in which yes
black panther was going to be this thing
it was unavoidable
you could not not see Black Panther so
it gets to be this just landmark moment
in on screen and behind the screen
University because they knew we were
gonna see it anyway and it will take a
LGBT creator to come in and say here's
the story I want to tell I want to do
she-hulk and you know what mushy Hulk is
gonna be gay she hug sign me up
and bam like then it happens because it
comes at organic and it's part of the
story and Disney Marvel will get behind
it because it's integral to the way
we're talking the story I think I think
they're they're the ones who are going
to get that done and whether it's gonna
be in Captain Marvel who knows whether
it's gonna be phase 12 yeah you know but
I think I think I think we get it but
black panther was an arc that was
already filled to bursting with other
things that had to do yeah cuz if it was
a series like like Black Lightning right
Black Lightning the eldest daughter
she's in a relationship with another
girl and what was great about it wasn't
like this it was a coming out episode
where I'm gonna tell my parents and I'm
yeah you know it was like she was just
it was just her relationship and they
treated that way and that's how it
should be it shouldn't have to be this
special fanfare that happens it was
looks like it was a scene we moved on
it's like oh wow she's with her
girlfriend okay cool and then you just
move on to the next scene and with you
know because that is how the world is
and it's respect
you guys recommend to begin something
I can't I can't get into it because
we're right now in the middle of it my
writing partner but we do have a pilot
in a series that we're really gonna try
to push this year and we've been trying
to push for a long time but you know now
it's like look back Black Manta four in
a million dollars let's do this can we
do this now please but yeah but but yeah
one of the one of the characters it does
take place in the late 1800s and it
takes the place of the five nations and
it's in the badlands evoke you know in
the twin territories and and and it's
talks about the Light Horse policeman
and you know the so it's very it I can't
like I said I really can't go into it
but definitely there is a character that
in there that's very important and I
think that if we're able to you know
tell that it will we'll be able to tell
those stories and hopefully uh fingers
crossed that will that will happen yeah
I am currently on a show with two Native
American leads for Netflix that will be
coming out next year it's supernatural
horror but isn't scouts counties yes HBO
for a while let me throw out the super
corny answer you can do it no no no not
not nothing that you just said right now
obviates you from doing it thank you
like you you said there could be cool
action like you can do it and it's gonna
be lo-fi right and it's gonna be like
some [ __ ] you writing on the blog it's
gonna be you know like but like that's
where it starts like you know I'm lucky
enough to be writing a black panther
series from Marvel Comics but like the
reason I'm writing is because like I've
had this [ __ ] in my head for years right
you didn't go in there like look I'm I'm
deadly at martial arts you know and it's
like I actually used to rule a kingdom
so I'm very qualified to write this
absolutely right that you know be the
change you want to see in the world and
if you don't if you don't see what you
what you feel is representative of your
story tell that story and truthfully
that's why we're all up here
yeah and that's that's what motivates us
that's what keeps us you know that's
keep us going and you you know you're no
different it's like if you have that
story that you want to tell and you know
not to be selfish like saying like well
I got mine but you know my bad I forgot
you know this is about you yeah that's
there there absolutely right you know
it's like there's nothing to stop you
especially in this day and age there's
so many ways to get your story out there
you just got to tell your story and when
I get to write the store movie I'm a
fortunate so we do not have time yeah
are you asking like what's our warrior
Falls moment as we're wrestling a giant
guy until you murder don't do that don't
do that really don't this that's bad
well now like we have the tools like I'm
just gonna start barking yes I I worked
at at a major weekly entertainment
magazine
I don't really yeah what one could that
be I don't know it's like Vogue or
something and and this was back in like
the the early 2000s when Tyler Perry
movie started to come out with
regularity and and and every February
which is when they seem like they came
out for reasons that escape me we would
end up writing this story that said
surprise Tyler Perry movie makes 22
million dollars in top the box office
next year
hey news Tyler Perry movie number one in
the box office next year hey would you
believe it and I and I think it was a
senior writer at the time which sounds
way more impressive than it is but I
have to say it like sitting up in a
meeting surrounded by you know white
people and tell them guys we cannot be
surprised by something that happens
every time like he's just making us look
bad you know like the the idea of truth
to power is a difficult thing to reckon
with especially when you're you know 28
29 years old and you've never had to do
that before but you believe that a thing
that we're about to do is wrong you know
that what I'm trying to save you from
yourself which which much of my
journalism career has been about in one
fashion or another trying to save
magazines from themselves here the
magazine I'm I'm the magazine whisperer
[ __ ] I'm the bag advantage of
magazines because
so you're the magical meter I mean the
magical is Negro you were because I was
almost always the only person of color
sitting on those tables and and every
time someone would come down the pike
he would fall to me I wish it hadn't
every time but to have to be the person
to say guys we're making a mistake
guys this is kind of the wrong way I
swear to god you're not gonna want to
print that if you do here's what's gonna
happen you know and then when you run
into magazines like I don't know major
weekly entertainment magazines that do
[ __ ] like put Black Panther on the cover
of their magazine with a caption that
says meow mm-hmm and there's no black
people working there to be like maybe
don't infantilize the first black
superhero maybe don't diminish who this
character is and what he means no I'm
not really [ __ ] happen yeah my dad
lost his [ __ ] mind because there's
nobody there to say guys I swear to god
you're not gonna want to do this you
think it's clever it's a horrible idea
and I spent you know a decent part of 20
years in journalism being the guy who
had to say I'm sorry dear white people
this is probably a bad idea
so yeah like it's it's sometimes it's
embarrassing to have to wrestle with the
total tonnage of a culture as the sole
representative of that culture in a
place but if I don't do it who's gonna
do it
you know like if you don't if you don't
I'm again I'm not the [ __ ] hero of
magazine journalism know what the killer
of magazines because you know I mean I
did work at playboy once it's it's at
some point you will find yourself in
position where you know what the right
thing to do is and
I mean I've I've not done the right
thing a bunch of times but every now and
again you know you got to sleep you got
to sleep with yourself before you sleep
with anybody else yes
why are you guys ruining my perfect
metaphor I had the most you know when
you feel like nerves
and you feel that trickle of sweat from
your armpit like yeah
so the one time for me was does anybody
here remember Resident Evil 5 okay that
was the one in Africa oh yeah no no was
it four am I [ __ ] it up the district
trauma around all of it I wish but so in
my job as a video game journalist I had
to interview the the lead of Resident
Evil 5 and I had to put to him the
question why are these black people like
this why do they look like zombies and
freaks and living walking stereotypes in
this in this horror game like why is the
one playable black character psychic
character three shades lighter than the
people that she came from the same
country and you know why I basically put
told what why we subhuman in this game
and it was the hardest [ __ ] interview
I've ever had to do because he stumbled
and like I tried to make him understand
the weight of the puck up and you know
there's a lot of noise made about
cultural differences and how that stuff
doesn't exist there in Japan and it
wasn't an embarrassing moment but it was
one like I felt like either you're
walking up to this bridge like and and
you're jumping to the other edge that's
broken and you make it or you don't
but like there's no way
not do it yeah I mean I could have not
then I kind of walked away from it and
been a puff piece interview but like
that's I was the only person the room
was gonna ask those questions nobody
else was embarrassed good for you guys
all right we got time for one more
question
there's just too many to tell I know I
mean the county here lady oh no wait you
got the mic already all right then two
questions
whoa whoa madam Agee good Lu Toya that's
me kung fu queen
do you guys think that I guess I mean
you know like I've had to get into a lot
of into a headspace for T'Challa
writing the comic right and you know one
thing that separates T'Challa from Steve
Rogers or Peter Parker like his actions
have like large-scale repercussions
right he's responsible for the whole
fate of the people like if he [ __ ] up
it's not just like okay lick your wounds
go home and fight doc talk to the next
day again you know like what come on to
Falls the whole history and the legacy
that he's preserve his entire life like
disappears like you know and right yeah
yeah and you know I guess there's
there's a there's there's a mode of
thinking that I often fall back to which
is that you know most superhero
characters are aspirational right they
show us what we can achieve that are at
our best and our worst and the
complexities of human nature like you
know when they're done really well but
also they maintain a status quo right
like most severe owes maintain a status
quo like they they they uphold the laws
of the land some of them they
interrogate whether those laws are just
well like you know never had a superhero
you know overturn and unjust American
election right they weren't trying to
[ __ ] they were trying to get Al Gore
into office like like back in the day
they were couch ads like they maintain
the status quo so I feel like you know
not to use that as an excuse but it's
it's in an element of the framework
within that you can talk about the
status school there's just or not but
like yeah I think the larger issue is
that you know he has to consider not
just his own wants and needs but like
what's best for the country was not
considering what was best for the
country
he was considering that it was best for
the diaspora and even then it was an
extreme mode but I think there's
something to what you're saying
I mean [ __ ] am I gonna say this better
than that let's go to the person with
the cat ears so last question and before
before we do the last question everybody
in the house tonight if you would like
to go we are holding in the brand-new
car Mart got deep pockets
fYI Derek said that Derek is buying all
your [ __ ] in new car it runs on
vibranium there's a there's a theater in
Koreatown
the only one of its kind in the country
that is outfitted with screen x10 about
the screen X where it's huge your movie
screen like normal everything goes cool
the theater is built then with wings on
the side so that the visual information
caresses you at like a 200 degree angle
sexy there's a screening of Black
Panther on Wednesday that everybody who
was here can go to for free wait does
that include us that includes us the
RSVP to Black Panther scream X at
gmail.com
it's 725 Wednesday night you walk out
but if you'd like to go Black Panther
screen X at gmail.com email that address
they'll give you the information the
address I will be there I don't know if
keval be there buddy might but it's
[ __ ] free so no and you will not see
it like this anyplace else in the
country so come on down so now no
pressure yeah
her shoes are glowing like they must be
made in Wakanda everybody's mom does I
mean asking as our ages I I feel like it
a lot of that depends on who that 50 67
year old person is you know like I
remember going to see darkest hour in
the theater you know the world war two
was the Joe show thing and a matinee
cause I'm gainfully unemployed and I was
sitting in this theater you know I'm not
gonna say what sold out but it was sold
out and they were all like 72 year old
white people was this the landmark in
Westwood no no's deep in the valley but
you went to one of those critics to the
world yes like we've dubbed that the the
elderly theater yeah and so before the
darkest hour the [ __ ] Black Panther
trailers pulls up as I'm sitting there
just looking around like how y'all
diggin this how do you feel about it
what's happening are we cool with right
and it's just like glass faces like one
person was like is that about Huey
Newton
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you know like nobody got up and left
cuz you were still getting like
crusty-ass boost insertion later but
that is not the audience that is going
to naturally come to Black Panther
unless the one of their kids takes them
you know and if one of their kids takes
them they're gonna kind of enjoy it
because if you if you can swing with
blue kittens in space there's no reason
you can't swim with black people on
earth
nice you know like and and my parents I
think I'm so [ __ ] steel like that but
like you know there there is a vast
segment of the population has never seen
themselves there's a vast thing the
population has never seen themselves
adjacent to there's nothing in this
movie that again is any different than
Excalibur you know it's about you know
royal succession it's about Thrones it's
about power it's not hunger it's about
revenge it's about isolation it's also
about hope and inspiration I think
because of the you know we didn't talk
about but the Afro futurism in it it's
just like the promise of what could be
you know I mean little kids looking at
that it's about so many [ __ ] things
and if you're a person who enjoys
content of any kind you will find
something to enjoy in this movie you
just have to open yourself up to it and
that that is where I fear the
generational divide will take place is
the the unwillingness to open themselves
up to what is a profoundly moving
cinematic experience I wish they would
you know it would help the next two
years go down a bit easier but isn't
there a part of you just saying like
[ __ ] them you can't save them all you
know and it just like
well you got the energy in it oh man
they're chips in the ears I don't have
energy the movie has another child the
movies gonna do all the goddamn have you
lifting all I got to say you know it's a
really good movie Black Panther you
should check it out
my pleasure that is it for this episode
of famine on bad manners you guys have a
good time whatever I would like to thank
our esteemed [ __ ] panel Deric Hughes
where can I find you on the Internet
scary Jews follow me on Twitter at D
blacken ease because you're black and
Japanese that it's correct
shout out to my Asian folk yes Evan our
seats where they gonna find you
and rise it up Black Panthers coming up
monthly from Marvel Comics I wish I wish
make that [ __ ] happen there yeah we
where everybody find comic books a Kayla
two / Cooper on Twitter I worked on a
show that shall not be named for legal
reasons right now but should be dropping
this you can mention it's on your
[ __ ] IMDB page I know seriously you
guys you have no idea there you go
Latoya Morgan where can the people find
more of you yes Twitter and Instagram
morgana kink that's what I am and into
the Batman has new season dropping in
April yeah
excellent and I have been walking
arguing for this episode of fat man on
Batman
same bat-time same bat-channel come back
next week SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith good night big ups to
mark barnard
[Applause]
[Music]
you